le ministère russe de la défense a fait
part ce jeudi d'une intensification des
opérations des forces aériennes des
états unis et de l'alliance atlantique
près de la frontière russe dans la
région de la mer noire au cours de la
dernière journée quatre avions de
reconnaissance de l'otan ont été
détectés et accompagnés par les systèmes
radar des unités de missiles
anti-aériens des forces aérospatiale
russe les vols des avions de
reconnaissance
u2 src 135 est de deux patrouilleurs
p-8a poseidon ont été effectués dans
l'espace aérien au dessus des partis
nord ouest et centrale de la mer noire
la russie surveille également les
déplacements de deux navires américains
dans la mer noire d'après le ministère
russe de la défense ces manoeuvres
constitue une agression menaçant la
russie le ministère russe de la défense
considère l'activité militaire des
etats-unis et de leurs alliés dans la
région de la mer noire comme une étude
d'un théâtre d'opérations militaires
potentielles dans le cas où l'ukraine
préparerait une solution militaire au
conflit dans le sud est le fait de mener
ces exercices imprévu près de nos
frontières constitue une action
agressive de la part des états unis qui
n'est absolument pas provoqué par la
russie et qui présentent une menace pour
la sécurité régionale et la stabilité
stratégique le président vladimir
poutine a lui-même évoqué ses actes de
provocation dangereux et déstabilisant
au cours d'un entretien téléphonique
avec un gala merkel ce jeudi